Hey guys, and welcome to episode number
28 of my 1hour flipping challenge. Today
we're going to be doing another uh
similar challenge to the last one where
we're going to start with a certain
amount of cash and see how much we can
make in 1 hour. Today we're going to
start with 100k. Uh so very little uh
and we're going to have to look for
items that are under 100k. Not sure how
many good ones will be out there to
flip, but we should expect some good
returns and high margins because the
items are a lot cheaper. Uh now for the
next episode, I'm thinking of doing a
user submitted challenge. Uh so what it
will be is you guys leave your comments
on this video uh for items that I could
flip in that episode and I will only
flip items suggested
suggested by people in the comment
section. So uh ideally we get a few
comments and I can flip those items. If
I only get 10 comments, then uh it's
going to kind of suck. If you guys just
say potatoes and rakes and random stuff
like that, it's going to suck, but I'm
going to do it anyway. And uh we'll give
it our best shot no matter the result.
All right, let's get started. All right,
we're ready to get started. So, we have
100k cash. Uh we're down. This is our I
guess fourth episode where we just start
from a different cash stack amount. And
I'm actually kind of excited for this
one. 100k is not a lot, but um just
quickly looking at G Tracker, it seems
like there are some items that might
offer a pretty good margin. Um so yeah,
let's get started. 1 hour and a clock.
Let's go. Okay, so once again, we're
going to be using G Tracker for most of
the items. Uh and we're just going to
use the filters up here. Uh so we'll
filter down to 100,000 for our max price
and the buying quantity minimum and
maximum.
Sorry, we don't want a maximum. I don't
know why I put the maximum. buying
quantity minimum and selling quantity
minimum, sorry, uh is going to be five
just so we get items that are being
traded at least. Uh so now we got a
couple new ones here. Actually, one I
did want to try was the uh red topaz
machete. Going to be a slow item, but I
think it might have good margin. Might
be able to flip one or two of those in
the hour. Um also is coming up is a
combat bracelet. Six. Interesting. May
try that first. Let's put an offer in
for this red machete.
All right. So, uh, let's see. G Tracker
is saying, "Buy it for about 15.5K and
sell it for 24." That seems good to me.
We'll buy it for 1601K.
Red topaz machete.
Okay, so we put in one red uh topaz
machete for 16k. And I think next up,
we're going to try the combat bracelet
six. uh surprisingly does not trade that
much per hour. Uh but 8k margin mar mar
mar mar mar mar mar mar mar mar mar mar
mar mar mar mar mar mar mar mar margin
on that. All right, so we opened up the
combat bracelet and it looks like it has
a very large like it's gone up quite a
bit in this last hour. Um so we'll try
buying it for 22k. Uh it's kind of a
weird item to be that high, but we'll
give it a try. Uh we could stand and
lose a little bit on this one, but we'll
put an offer in for 22k. Hm.
Interesting. The urg bone.
I kind of have a feeling that these
might not come in very consistently.
probably all at once or not at all would
be my guess, but we'll have a look at
the day stats just in case. Um, well,
about six an hour.
I'm not sure that many people are buying
these though, so I think I might pass on
that.
Mystic robe top bottoms.
I mean, how much do we have? Do we have
enough to buy that 58k?
Uh, yeah, we do actually. I think we'll
go for that. All right. All right. So, I
think we're going to try buying Okay,
mystic robe bottom.
Darkness. And we'll try buying it for
we have open here somewhere.
55k maybe roughly.
Yeah, we'll go for a 55.
Uh 55 550.
Uh yeah, sure. We'll go for that. And
that's unfortunately all our money used
up. So, we'll have to wait a little
while for uh some of these items to come
in. Okay, surprisingly the mystic robe
top bot or rob bottom. Sorry, it's not a
top. I mean, you could put it on your
top if you wanted, but you look like a
[__] idiot. Uh anyway, that came in
first surprisingly. Um I thought the
comic braz would come first for sure,
but uh we'll try selling it for
um let's try 65k.
That's not decent margin. I mean, if you
consider the percent return on this,
that is extremely good. I'm lagging.
What? Okay, I think we're good. Um,
that's a 5k margin on 60k item.
Wait, 10k.
That's a little ambitious. Well, we'll
leave it in there for a while. 10k on a
60k item is insanely good. Um,
considering that would be 10% back on
our money right there. Uh but of course
when you're flipping with smaller
amounts uh the margin returns tend to be
much higher. Hey, there we go. Uh we
just reduced the mystic rope top to 63k
and did end up selling. So that is a
decent margin there. Well, I guess 8.5k.
Uh so we'll go ahead and buy another one
of those and that'll leave us with 13k.
And we did actually have a combat
bracelet coming through. 22k. Now, the
for some reason, if we look at the
combat bracelet, the amount traded has
just plummeted. I guess it might be the
time of night, but anyway, um there just
is not anyone selling it cuz look, one
sold for 60k. That's crazy. Uh so, we'll
try selling it for 35k. I know it seems
crazy, but we found an item that is
normally high demand at this time of
night and when no one's selling it, I
would
feel feel totally comfortable that
someone actually buy it because when you
want a combat bracelet, you need a
combat bracelet. You're not going to
wait uh for the price to go back down.
So, I think it definitely could sell for
35k. So, we're going to leave it in
there.
Uh next up I want to try the procelite
halberg. Uh because once again it is a
item that does trade a lot but just
right now it's very slimly traded. Uh
only maybe
six an hour. Uh but we'll go ahead and
try buying look that margin. We'll try
buying it for around 7k
7.7. We'll go for Yeah, we'll go for
7.7k.
Proite
I can spell this [__] item. Frost
light harbor. We'll go for 8k. 801.
And uh well, that'll leave us with 6k
left. Not a lot, but uh yeah, hopefully
some more of these items will come
through uh so we can get some more
profit. Okay, we got two things
completing. For one, we did actually
manage to sell that combat bracelet for
35k.
I know it seems crazy, but uh if you
have a look at the charts, it's just
look at that. It's in flux. No one is
selling them right now. It's just me. I
was surprised I was actually able to
snag one. So, we'll definitely put
another offer in for that. Uh 22k has a
crazy margin for combat bracelets. And
surprisingly, we got another one of
these mystic robe bottoms. Uh nothing
else so far, but we'll go ahead and sell
that for 63k is what we sold it for
before. Yeah, 63k.
This is going way better than the last
time I tried this. And yeah, still
haven't gotten the pros light armor or
the red topaz machete yet, but we do
actually have 18k, which is pretty
substantial. That sounds stupid, but um
can let's refresh this page quickly. 7k
into 14k. That would be seems a little
crazy, but I I don't know. I guess it's
just a time of night. See, look, we got
another comet bracelet coming through
for 22k. Um we'll maybe try selling it
for a little bit less this time because
it did take a while to sell. 33k. Don't
want to get too greedy now. and a red
dehide body.
Red Dragoney body. We'll try buying for
uh maybe 7k.
Uh 701.
We'll go for two of those. Uh because
they should trade pretty frequently. And
yeah, we'll up to Oh, there we go. We
got a red topaz machete coming through.
16k. And uh we're going to try selling
that for 24k. I can remember now. 23998.
Very good margin on that. Oh, and we got
the mystic robot coming through as well
for 63k.
Nice. That is another 8K on that. We're
going to put another offer for one of
those. 55 550. We are rigging in the
cash on those. And well, we got another
12k now. I don't think we can afford any
of these items. We could just put
another offering for the red dehide, but
what? Okay, we got another mystic robot.
Mystic robot. Mystic robe bottom coming
through. Popping them for 63k.
They're going ridiculously quick. All
right. Uh, we'll just leave it for now.
All right. We have the Proite Halbert
coming in for 8001.
Now, I can't remember
what we're going to sell it for again.
Oh, we have it open. 8001. How does
Again, this is an item where if people
need it, they're going to want to they
need it. They're going to buy it. They
don't care about an 8K difference. Uh,
so we'll put it in for
um we'll put in for 17k. How about
17k? I doubt anyone else is selling
this, honestly. It's just going to be
me. Okay, next up, we have the red dehy
bodies coming through. Uh, we bought
them for 7K and I'm hoping to maybe get
a 2K margin. Uh, yeah, I'll try selling
them for 9K. Swear to God, just a second
later, another one of these came through
for 63K. Uh, we're making bank off this
item. Um, 15 55 55 50. God, there's 75s
in there. [__] it. Let's put another
five in.
There we go. Mix it up.
Another mystic robot coming in for 55.
555.
I am just impressed by how quickly this
item has flipped what, like five of
these already in the time that each of
these have flipped one. What? What? Who
is doing this? I literally just
got to get these in. Maybe someone else
is checking the margin over and over
again. What the hell? I am just so
shocked by how well this is going.
Combat bracelet coming in for 29k. That
is a 22k or 22k. 7k margin on the combat
bracelet. Very nice. Going to go buy
another one of those. Uh red topaz
machete coming in for 23998.
Um
what is that? Is a 7k margin on that as
well. We'll go ahead and try to buy
another one of those. And I literally
just flip after flip.
63k. Toss that back in there.
I am. Wow. Wow. There it is. Another
mystic robot sold. 63k. I didn't
actually realize it would be this
popular, but uh we're lagging. Come on.
Come on. We got to get this item again
so someone else can buy it. And we got
another combat bracelet coming in for
22K. Going to sell the offer, what was
it? 29K.
And I think we might put another offer
in for the combat bracelet while we're
waiting here.
Copper bracelet for 22k.
So when an item is kind of in flux like
this, it is a great opportunity to make
a lot of money, but also you don't want
to don't leave offers like this in
overnight or something. Uh because of
course the item could crash easily and
then you'd be kind of screwed. Uh but
yeah, it's working out pretty well for
me. 41 into 44. Not as good as the other
items, but it's still passable. And I
couldn't really find another item at the
time. We'll try buying it for 42K. Go.
Okay, we're good. And we sold another
combat bracelet for another 7K profit.
Quite nice on that one. And nothing else
to report. Another mystic robot coming
in for 555.
Pop that in for 63K once again. All
right. Well, there we go. That might be
enough. Uh 63K. Bought. Sold another
one. Excuse me. I really hope the limit
on this is 70. Uh cuz this is such a
good item. I can't afford to not flip
the entire limit. H that's not going to
happen. But still 55k, 7k. We must have
flipped that what? Eight times now.
Quite a few times. All right, we finally
sold off the proite hob for 17k. Uh I
didn't really record how long that was
going to take. It's even on here.
Bought it for We'll try to buy another
one. We bought it for 8K. That has a 10k
merge gun on that. But we're going to
double our money easily here. We got
another mystic rope top coming in. Sell
that for 63k.
I'm another mystic rope top coming in.
That's going to be another 63k we're
going to sell that for. Who needs Zoro
when I can continue to flip these over
and over and over again. Another 7k on
those. Another 555. going to buy it for.
Uh the far ear helm came through for
44k. Uh not again not a huge margin, but
I don't really have a better item, so
we'll toss that in again. All right,
another mystic robe bottom piece. 55k.
Going to merch that again for 63.
And uh 21k left. We must have broken
double by now. I would be very impressed
if we hadn't. Okay, I think I'm going to
put another offer in for the red deodes.
I don't really have anything else to put
in for. And we'll try buying
six of them. Another far share helmet
coming in for 42k.
Not bad. We're going to flip that for
another 2k profit. Okay. Another mystic
robot coming in for 63k. On top of that,
we have bought uh five of the red dragon
eye bodies. Uh
what? Okay, six, I guess. Feel like a
lot of weird things are happening right
now. Anyway, we're going to try selling
them for 9K once again. Pop them in
there for 9K. That'll be a 18k profit on
that, which is quite nice. Another
mystic rope bottom coming in for 63k.
And um well, we'll try buying two more
of those, I guess. All right, we have
the fire helm coming in as well for 44k.
Not bad. And well, we'll just continue
to buy those. And can't get over how
quickly those are coming through. 42k.
We got another one coming in. 55k. Going
to toss in for 63 again.
We've probably merged uh 100k worth of
this in profit which is amazing. Okay,
something finally different coming in.
The proite hopper for 8k and another
mystic robot. Popped in for 63 of course
and the halberg for how the [__] do you
say that? Halberg. I think halberg
sounds better. Anyway, we're selling
that for 18k, wasn't it? 17k. Still
extremely nice. Another fire chair helm
coming in for 42k. Uh again, 2k on that.
I'm very surprised by how slowly the red
dehides are selling. Um they bought
pretty quick, but surprisingly no one is
buying them. Guess people training
crafting could potentially be selling
them to me, but yeah, a little strange.
Okay, with the proite hopper coming in,
uh we did end up reducing the price a
bit till 14k and then it did sell. Uh, I
think we're going to start just waiting
for the items to sell because we only
have 12 minutes left. And uh, well,
these should honestly sell quickly.
Although, I may have gotten undercut on
the margin because uh, they haven't sold
in a little while now. And yeah, I think
we could reasonably sell this in 12
minutes. Okay, so both our Mystic
Robottoms have come through. Another 7K
just around at the hour. Uh, looking
very promising. We
should h finish with more than 200k,
which is going to be a net profit of
200% or more, which is by far the most
I've gotten in any of my episodes. Of
course, this is largely uh due to the
fact that our item choices have been
such a low cash amount, which does lead
to higher margins. But still very
impressed and happy with how this went.
Okay, we're ended about 4 minutes left
and we sold our far seer helm. Uh final
flip. Probably did four or five of
those. Uh only 2k in each one, but we're
already up to 200k. Uh and well, we
still have these red eyes to sell. Not
selling very quickly, unfortunately. But
uh yeah. Oh well. Even if we get stuck
with a few, we're not going to lose any
money, I don't think. Okay, guys. So,
we're down to about a minute remaining.
I do not believe we're going to sell the
red dehides, but that's okay. Um still
extremely happy with how the hour went.
By far the best item was this mystic
robe bottom. Uh we must have sold 10 to
15 of those. Uh so probably close to 100
to 125k in profit off of just that item.
Uh we flipped two proite halls which I
think may have had the best margin. Uh
10k very good. Did two of those and red
topaz knife was good. Honestly all the
items were decent. Uh but of course the
mystic robot uh was the best. Anyway, I
think we're just going to pull these out
cuz I don't think they're selling. Uh 17
seconds left. It's pretty much an hour
and we'll go ahead and insta sell these
for
well 6.6k each. Didn't lose much on
there. But anyway, we're finishing up
with 244K. That is excellent. Has a 250%
return, which is blasting any even out
of the water that was close to before. I
think the best I had before was uh 20%
or something. Uh anyway, mostly due to
the cheapness of the items, but still I
can't deny that was still extremely
good. Anyway, so I hope you guys enjoyed
and I will see you guys in the next
episode.
[Music]